So who cared. So if I come to you right now, let's go back. You're the,
your mortgage broker in long Island. I meet you in a diner,
which is you call your office.
Period. Diner. Freeport. Absolutely phenomenal. Yeah. You got to make it real.
So see period diner and Freeport on Barry Crow.
Yeah. You say, meet me at the office and you, I hear you. Hey.
That will spill hot coffee. Anybody was taking a look at you and go. Yeah.
Yeah. And when you tell me to meet you at your office,
I hear the clang of a payphone when you hang up. And so I meet your office.
I come in, I say, Hey, how you doing? Nice to meet you, Mr. Dylan,
me and my wife just got married. Um, you know, I'm a comedian.
I saved up about 80 K um, uh, you know,
she wants to live and we're having a baby who wants to launch. You got pop.
I'm very glad.
I get alone. Not only can you get along, but let me, let me tell you some. Yeah.
How much that 80 K are you prepared to spend on the property?
I don't know. Uh, Mr. Dylan, you know,
I'm pretty conservative guy saved every single dollar from my mortgage.
How much you prepared us banked. Um, hold on. Let me go into Marissa.
No, no, no, no. Of that 80,000. How much would you like to spend?
Are you willing to spend all of that?
I'm willing to spend more to spend about 60 or 70 of it.
Guess how much of that is? You're going to have to spend how much, nothing.
What? Nothing.
You're not going to spend anything because let me explain something to you.
Sit down. The wife is lovely. Would you like a cup of coffee? Yeah,
here's the thing. Could we, could I get pancakes while I'm here?
You can get anything. The bricks and sticks of your house.
Appreciate the frame, the land, they appreciate value.
You know what your money does in your house for you, Mr. Papas,
it does absolutely nothing.
You know what the wealthiest people do with real estate, Mr. Papas,
a lot of them finance it. Why? Because your mortgage is your only tax.
Write off.
It is the only write-off is your only weapon against the
federal government.
The larger the loan you take the better it is for you financially.
And you take that $80,000 and he, and I'm not wrong by the way,
let me put lime a little and you put it in tax exempt,
securities like Roth IRAs. Mr. Papas,
you maximize the amount of,
of tax exempt retirement accounts that you put your money in with that
$80,000. You make it work for you. You do not sink it into a house.
Yes or yes.
So the reality is this we're taking the biggest loan possible.
Mr. Papas will set you free.
Now sign this piece of paper for Christ. And at that point,
you and your wife were crying and then we signed papers and you do. You go down,
how do you get the loan from the bank? They're giving them away.
We're talking about now, we're back in the day. Back in the day, I said, Kelly,
we got one at Kelly. I said,
Mr. Papas and his wife Brittany's from long Island.
They want to go buy a piece of marble. Honk is,
Kelly, ice got Coke running down in Melbourne. From last night,
she's got a double tall non-fat latte from Starbucks.
Non-fat she's not getting anyone. And she melts it down. And she says, let me,
she makes all the paperwork look like it should look. And the, my little bank,
which was called Franklin first or new world mortgage or the mortgage zone,
or if the funding hot or whatever it is, we send our paper to a,
even bigger. And as similarly, bank,
like a long beach mortgage, or a new century mortgage or an Argent,
and those banks were doing backdoor deals with JP Morgan city group.
So those banks were underwriting the paper to the,
to the middle grade banks that were lending money to the dirt bed,
brokerage operating out of a van. Places that I work. Okay.
So when this all, they were playing a game of hot potato, that's an orgy. Yeah.
So when, so when everything goes wrong, you pass it around,
pass the basket around. And then by the time you sign your mortgage,
by the time you get your first bill, cause the other benefit Mr. Papas,
you don't pay for two months, right? For two months, you don't pay.
But are you sure I'm going to be able to afford this mortgage by standup comedy
career is up and down.
Mr. Papas, I have watched your stuff. I think you're a genius. Thank you.
And I think you're absolute genius. And I will tell you this right now.
All you have to worry about right now is,
is what are you going to do?
I'm just a little worried. I'm not past the seller. Am I going to have a future?
What if you're going to have a seller in the home that we put you in?
All you have to worry about as a pop is what are you going to do with those two
free months? Cause we're rolling it into the mortgage. You've got 60 days.
I would take a little vacation with this lovely lady. Are you serious too?
I was concerned. I even had enough for the mortgage before this two free months.
What? Yeah, that's what you're saying. Free.
Am I going to have to pay at some point for this.
Rolling into the mortgage, which again,
we talked about it just increases your tax deduction. If you could, Mr. Papas,
you take a loan every day, honey,
I have read that you would take a loan because the federal government is coming
to take your hard earned money.
I am telling you your ability to fight them is contingent on how big this
mortgage is. Take all your credit card debt or your car loans, everything,
student loans, roll it into this refinance.
It let's take a hundred thousand dollars, 200,000. Let's do it.
Let's make it big and let's do it once. Do it, right?
That's a great line. That's a line.
One of our guys had let's do it once and do a ride.
And then he called them back eight months later and they'd go, you said,
we've got to do it once and do it right? He goes,
let's do it twice and do it better. But that's what we need.
That's the only way that economies get like you guys can laugh at that.
That's the only way the economy is going to get on a bubble bath to sell things
to others.
Everything you explained, none of that is criminal at all. It's just, wow,
you wouldn't go so far as to say that. Yeah.
No, none of it was criminal. I didn't really do the criminal.
The criminal was really, um, and it was just some, a. It's not cause a morality.
The criminal really was well, we did a little criminal stuff to lie in the peat.
The people that was all my cousin,
my cousin owns a car dealership on Northern Boulevard is going to say that I've
worked there for the last six years.
Right. Look the other way and go, let's approve them for the mortgage the way.
Okay.
That's w that's kind of soft fraud because the bank was not,
it wasn't fake documents. It was literally, they were accepting, uh,
honor system.
Let me ask you this question is crazy. How did this orgy get started?
Is my first question. My second question is when did you know it was over?
And my third question is, can you compare it to stand-up comedy three questions?
When I, when the origin got started after.
Well, it started to two places. It started with the community reinvestment act,
uh, under the Clinton administration.
A lot of things that ended up being very bad, start with good positive things.
And like basically people were saying to.
Like communism, like communism, right? You gotta start expanding.
In minority communities. And, uh, low-income communities,
you got to expand opportunities to credit. People need to be, uh,
able to finance things, get into the American system.
They don't have that opportunity.
They're denied by banks all the time that we need to stop that.
So community reinvestment act planted the seeds in the heads of wall street,
people and financial, uh,
industry executives that they needed to come up with products that allowed them
to land to traditionally riskier borrowers, borrowers,
that might've had less income, less credit, less, less, you know, uh, whatever.
Um, um, and so what then happened was after nine 11,
the economy was in a recession and Alan Greenspan, you know, they cut rates,
fed cut rates. Uh, and then, then the party started where it was like,
now it was like, Hey, get, get in let's kick, start the economy.
We got to get some houses going on. And then it was a, uh, real estate boom,
a construction, boom. Um,
all of these exotic financial products that allowed you to pay one or 2% like a
credit card payment that's on the way. Sure.
Some version of that will be on the way on those financial products within
bundled up and sold, uh, to, uh,
investment funds and then people. And this is we're so interconnected.
What really everything was like people's pensions were tied into these funds
that were wrapped up with very toxic assets, which was the term,
which was bad mortgages,
mortgages given to people that had no ability to repay them. Uh,
and that's the mortgage backed security, which was invented by a guy named blue,
rainy, airy, uh, who's profiled in the big, short,
that was when they decided that mortgages should be traded and sold between
banks and investment, uh, institutions like stocks,
your bank used to hold your mortgage. So early on,
you would go to a mortgage bank and you would have the bank I'm in so many
scenes in old movies or guy arguing with the banker. It's been rough this month.
It's the banker that gave him the mortgage. He knew the guy.
It was a very localized thing. I know him, I know his farm.
I've been to his farm. I know what he brings in. Um,
and then everything got very global where like,
I would give you mortgage and sell it to Ghana.
So then y'all would sell it to pimp. And the pimp would sell to shell.
Chase would sell your chase would sell your mortgage to Fannie Mae, correct?
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac are GSEs government sponsored entities,
meaning they're not technically government controlled,
but they're government sponsored.
Meaning the government Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac are essentially why we have,
um, you know, some stability in the, in the mortgage market,
meaning that they back the loans,
they not explicitly, but they,
they ensure that these loans are good
and they protect banks who issue these loans and
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac are well, you know,
one of the reasons we have a 30 year mortgage,
do you have a stability over 30 years as a financial instrument?
That's kind of unheard of, and it's not common everywhere in the world.
It's very uncommon. I mean, a lot of places there's only 10 year notes,
a 30 year fixed note is, is, is, is a financial product that you work in.
This is what, like, the libertarians is tough.
And they start talking about like, Oh, the gov government,
the government's always been involved in everything. Yeah.
The government's allowed all of this to happen.
So this idea that like you can uncouple from the government, uh, is,
is just not realistic. It might've been, it ma I'll give them this.
It might've been better to not have the government do all of these things. Sure.
Academically great.
But the reality is even just looking at the mortgage market to redo and the real
great book.
If anyone has an interest in this is written by Bethany McClean,
and it's called all the devils are here.
And it's about a it's from a great Shakespeare play. All the devils are here.
I should say, Bethany McClean also wrote one of the most influential articles.
She's a reporter, a reporter for fortune. And she wrote a,
one of the most influential articles that's ever been written in finance.
And it was called how does Enron make its money?
And it was the first article that kind of pierced the facade of the Enron.
That book,
all the devils are here is about what the mortgage crisis depends on who you
blame more. Here's what it is there is it, was it more predatory lenders?
And Joan Rivers said on an episode of Louie? No. When you're lucky. Yeah. No.
When you're lucky, there's this idea, uh, of,
of our economies built on this model of perpetual growth, right?
Everything's gotta be bigger and bigger and bigger.
The house has got to be bigger. The pool's gotta be deeper.
The yard has got to be bigger. The debt is going to be bigger.
You got to know when to hand, you gotta know, you gotta know when to cash.
It's the disease of more, right? The disease of more and it's,
and it was those wall street guys weren't poor before they started slinging
these things. They weren't poor, but they got, you know, in the last 10 or 15,
20 years,
people in that line of work have gotten astronomically, wealthy,
a level of wealthy that most people don't understand. I'm talking about.
Many of them are earning a billion dollars in a calendar year or
over a hundred million dollars in a calendar year, right?
Not 30 million, not a million a month, not 2 million a month,
not 5 million a month. We're talking in cases, 20,
$30 million a month.
The guys at the top of those institutions they've become so
like dislocated from the city. There is a real,
like, you know, problem with that type of money.
This level,
it was the disease of more on the side of those who were getting the loans.
And on the side of people who were.
Correct, right. It's all across the board. It's the American dream.
And I knew it was over when I was in a diner in the same diner.
I said to the waiter, I sat, um, Hey, I, you know,
my order at the diner is always mozzarella sticks. Also.
I'd like a grilled cheese with Turkey. Cause I'm, I'm turning over a new lane.
Then I asked the waitress, where's the closest Carvel.
Grilled cheese with Turkey tomato. I'm turning over a new leaf.
I didn't say bacon. It's in Turkey. Now let me ask you a question.
If bacon goes in a sandwich with the Turkey,
Khosla, French fries, slightly cooked, but
don't burn them. Don't give me the,
don't give me the excuse that people are paying attention to there. So,
and uh, so I said, ah, I said to the waiter, he goes, what are you gonna do?
I said, I do mortgages. He goes, what a coincidence? I do mortgages.
And then the guy that was handing me, my mozzarella sticks,
took out a card from his top pocket and put it on the diner table.
And that's kind of the way I felt, you know,
about a year or year and a half ago in comedy.
When everyone you knew was that Matt was a comedian.
A problem is when everybody like, it's the secret's out. It's like, you know,
you ever go to a good restaurant.
So that's when you knew it was over when everyone was getting yeah.
When it got saturated, oversaturate food example,
which I don't talk to about food, a lot, a rush, you go to a good restaurant.
It's great.
Then you cruise by it on a Saturday night and it's jammed and you go,
I hope in a year from now,
we don't end up coming back and going this place socks.
But a lot of times that happens a lot of times when it,
when it's the secret place and they're on the come up, they're on the rise.
Everything's great.
But when it explodes and everybody's in and everybody's got their hand in the
trough, then all of a sudden people start making stupid decisions.
They start making bad decisions and the people should making decisions that are
nowhere near the actual decisions, which is why communism,
all these isms don't work is because people are making decisions from 30,000
feet about disciplines. They have no idea about how they actually work, right?
So when the government just goes, Hey, find a way to lend to low income people.
And wall street goes, we got it.
The government has no idea what's about to happen. Right?
And then the ones that kind of have an inkling,
just keep their mouth shut because things are good Bush because 70% of Americans
own homes,
Trump has done nothing but extend what Obama did, which was extended,
but pushed head,
which is essentially just tell people to put it all on a credit card.
That's just the whole thing. The economy is just on a card.
We'll think about it later. I mean, we owe, what is it? 20 trillion as China.
You don't, it's the number. Now. You can't even say the number anymore.
They got us to think of a new word in English language.
Describe the amount the economy is just on the card. It's an onlay way.
It's like w you know, interest rates, what happens when that culminates,
where does that end as all things? And what happens? How do we reconcile?
The inflation is where it ultimately leads to the devaluing of the dollar.
The dollar not being the world's reserve currency are our debt rating getting
trashed. We're not a good debtor anymore. So that means we're losing. Yeah.
AAA bond rating and all that. Yeah. That's where it leads.
And then it just leads to what you're talking about.
There is the actual rotting of the infrastructure of the Amtrak crack.
That's inability to service our debt. Our inability to,
you know,
basically print the kind of money that we've been printing to keep everybody off
the streets, which hasn't worked.
This is when you become a bad earner in the mafia, and then you get whacked.
You can become a blood earner.
Now we got somebody in the mafia.
Movies starts looking at a picture of you from the good times with sadness in
the past. You know, they take a picture.
They look at you when you guys all went to like a Ruba and you went, yeah,
that was fun. He used, that's where we're getting to has got a lot of debts.
Now we don't know how to really get them out. I, I think business is common.
It could be weed. It could be prostitution. I think you've got to legalize weed,
legalized prostitution.
They want to Biden or Trump's new administration whores you're in weed is in,
we do not have a choice. You don't have a choice.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe, uh,
turn on your notifications, get jiggy with it and go.
Patron.com/bay Ridge boys, where things get really.
Wild.